women have gotten so deluded that they
think that because they put all the
on their face that they actually look
like this they think because they froze
their face and they can't move their
eyebrows that thou now they are a higher
quality wife and mother and it's so
crazy because you get this from the left
and the right which is why sometimes I'm
telling you this face is very alienating
because these women are living in la la
land with their fake faces thinking
they're hotter than they are and it
doesn't really matter how hot you are
you can't change biology and the fact of
the matter is I checked that before
probably has more options than you when
it comes to a man's a family